mientras que los problemas de salud
física no suelen ser tema de
preocupación entre la población joven
cada vez son más quienes dicen tener
problemas de salud mental de hecho el
porcentaje de jóvenes entre los 15 y los
29 años que dicen sufrirlos de manera
frecuente en España ha aumentado de un
6% en 2017 a casi el 16% en 2021 de ahí
que este año la marcha por el día de la
Salud Mental en Madrid esté dedicada a
la juventud la adolescencia y la niñez
Bueno pues el principal factor y que nos
hemos dado cuenta ha sido la pandemia ha
habido como un Boom de casos Es cierto
que antes se invisibilizaba ahora se
empieza a ver más Pero ha habido un
aumento bastante bastante considerable
yo he venido por mí por familiares y por
amigos y porque es algo necesario que no
se le da la suficiente visibilidad
Pues creo que es una manera para hacer
ver que no hay que esconderse aunque sea
difícil que haya mucho pudor Aunque haya
mucho estigma creo que es necesario
mostrarse pese a los 100 millones de
euros que ha invertido el gobierno de
España para abordar los problemas de
Salud Mental derivados de la pandemia de
Kobe 19 los expertos aseguran que faltan
recursos para prevenir Y tratar este
tipo de enfermedades Es según ellos la
gran tarea pendiente de la sanidad
española qué más necesitamos pues sobre
todo apostar por una sanidad pública y
universal que de atención a todo el
mundo que necesitamos pues mucha
educación social no solamente las
escuelas sino a nivel social porque el
estigma se da en sociedad en los cinco
primeros meses desde que se activara la
línea de atención a la conducta suicida
el 0.24 implementada por el gobierno el
30% de las llamadas fueron hechas por
menores de 30 años un síntoma de que
quizás en esta sociedad Algo está
fallando